thousands of students in Seattle have 10
days to get vaccinated or they will not
be allowed to go to school
this comes after Washington State
suffered two measles outbreaks this year
one forcing a state of emergency this
year the US has seen nearly 1,300
measles cases through November the most
in 27 years Carter Evans has more on
Seattle's efforts to stop the spread the
Seattle Public Schools district is
issuing a new year's warning to parents
school notified us something we had to
get done if your kids aren't vaccinated
don't bring them back in December the
school districts website issued a notice
to family saying their kids could not
attend school until the required
information is provided to the school
nurse and students must be vaccinated by
January eighth if any students show up
on that on the eighth and they don't
have their records up to date they'll be
put aside in a room their parents will
be contacted to come and collect the
students Seattle's public school says
roughly 2,000 students still need
vaccines they're not alone measles
outbreaks in the US this year have
forced a number of states to take action
last December Rockland County in New
York barred unvaccinated children from
schools with low vaccination rates and
by June New York passed a new law that
applied to all public and private
schools in the state it eliminated
religious exemptions for vaccines the
state of Washington was hit hard this
year with 87 confirmed cases of the
measles in the wake of the outbreaks
Washington state law also banned vaccine
exemptions for personal or philosophical
reasons for measles mumps and rubella
and now Seattle schools are turning into
free immunization clinics to help she
vote my sleeve up and put alcohol on my
arm and I just got a shot today and
tomorrow two schools will be open for
vaccinations for CBS this morning I'm
Carter Evans got to keep the kids safe
it's an interesting step the school
districts take it really is but it's
controversial some people don't believe
in it
you